dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly FIFA here today we
are going to talk about a paper that
builds on a previous work by the name
deep image priors dip in short this work
was capable of performing JPEG
compression artifact removal image in
painting were in other words filling in
parts of the image with data that makes
sense
super resolution and image denoising it
was quite the package this new method is
able to subdivide an image into a
collection of layers which makes it
capable of doing many seemingly
unrelated tasks for instance one it can
do image segmentation which typically
means producing a mask that shows us the
boundaries between the foreground and
the background as an additional
advantage it can also do this for videos
as well too it can perform the hazing
which can also be thought of as a deck
and position tasks where the input is
one image and the output is an image
with haze and one with the objects
hiding behind the haze if you spend the
tiny bit of time looking at the window
on a hazy day you will immediately see
that this is immensely difficult mostly
because of the fact that the amount of
haze that we see is non-uniform along
the landscape the AI has to detect and
remove just the right amount of this
haze and recover the original colors of
the image and three it can also
subdivide these crazy examples where two
images are blended together in a moment
I'll show you a better example with a
complex texture where it is easier to
see the utility of such a technique and
for of course it can also perform image
in painting which for instance can help
us remove watermarks or other unwanted
artifacts from our photos this case can
also be thought of as an image layer
plus the watermark layer and the
algorithm is able to recover both of
them as you see here on the right a tiny
part of the content seems to bleed into
the watermark layer but the results are
still amazing it does this by using
multiple of these dips
deep image prior networks and goes by
the name double-dip that one got me good
when I first seen it you see here how it
tries to reproduce this complex textured
pattern as a sum of these two much
simpler individual components the
supplementary materials are available
right in your browser and show you a ton
of comparisons against other previous
works here you see the results of these
earlier works on image d hazing and see
that indeed the new results are second
to none and all this progress within
only two years what a time to be alive
if like me you'll have information
theory who make sure to have a look at
the paper and you'll be a happy person
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects it is
like a shared logbook for your team and
with this you can compare your own
experiment results put them next to what
your colleagues did and you can discuss
your successes and failures much easier
it takes less than five minutes to set
up and is being used by open AI to yura
research Stanford and Berkeley it was
also used in this open AI project that
you see here which we covered earlier in
the series they reported that experiment
tracking was crucial in this project and
that this tool saved them quite a bit of
time and money if only I had access to
such a tool during our last research
project where I had to compare the
performance of neural networks for
months and months well it turns out I
will be able to get access to these
tools because get this it's free and
will always be free for academics and
open source projects make sure to visit
them through wendy be calm slash papers
w AMD be calm slash papers or just click
the link in the video description and
sign up for a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time